so my friend mark rober has graduated
from detonating glitter bombs on package
thieves to actually
catching scammers in the act and many
people asked
can mark's evidence actually be used in
court
and the answer is it depends because it
always depends but
probably more likely than not there are
a couple of overlapping issues here
number one is chain of custody
when you have evidence you have to show
that it is what it purports to be and
it's authentic and mark can probably
demonstrate this through
lots and lots of videographic evidence
officer i don't know what happened and
then there's the evidentiary issue a lot
of these videos are going to be hearsay
it's technically considered hearsay
evidence
but as you know if you watch this
channel there are lots of exceptions and
they probably apply here and then
finally there are statutory things like
rules against videotaping people
privacy laws and here it gets a little
dicey but query whether you have an
expectation of privacy if you're engaged
in manifest illegal activity
but this is going to change it's going
to be case by case good for mark for
taking the initiative and trying to
catch some of these bad guys it's
fascinating go watch his video or i'll
see you
in court